[Music]
is it at all intimidating to do a movie
like this with Tom Cruise who has been
doing stunts forever it's kind of his
thing his thing and he really does
everything and wants to do everything
even if the stunt guys and the producers
like please right he's not he's not
afraid to take chance
no no and so you kind of want to do your
own stunts as well because you don't
want him to be the only one showing off
yeah you do a stunt in the movie that I
kept thinking this looks so real
but they must have CGI'd this and then I
find out you didn't it's the one where
you're driving oh yeah the car and and
I'm not gonna give it away but Tom
Cruise is next to you and the car and
you it looks like it's impossible to
fake it's something you look like you're
driving I was driving it we were driving
this crazy old car with a big trailer
behind it and the stunt guy was like
right you know I want you to like go
really fast down the path and then take
a really hard right and I want the
trailer to like swing out behind you so
get it moving and like him it could be
kind of violent I was like great Tom
Cruise is in the passenger seat not his
favorite place today he's not in control
I don't think it's in his fabric to like
being a passenger in a stunt driving
scene right right he wants to be behind
the wheel and so so we do first take it
went really well
stunt stunt guy came over you went okay
just do it again and try and do it even
faster I was like no problem
so we start I tear down this part and
Tom's being very quiet behind me and
suddenly I just hear him under his
breath as I approach the right-hand turn
I hear him going brake brake brake brake
Oh God Oh God and bravery brake
brake braking our breathing and I left
it too late and so drove us into a tree
Tom Cruise oh my god I can't believe
this was even allowed to happen in my
head I was thinking when I first time to
say brake in my head I went you know
as if I thought I knew more about Sun
driving than Tom Cruise yeah I obviously
was like he knows nothing he knows
nothing you need to say I got this I've
got this so what do you do you crash
into a tree and there's got to be that
moment afterwards where the airbags have
gone off you're oh you're sitting there
and you realize I I've almost killed Tom
crow I what is he saying laughing and he
was actually laughing and I told him I
said I thought you were being so
annoying when you told me I apologize